it's almost six months since sudan's
military seized power and the opposition
remains vocal on wednesday protesters in
the capital khartoum and several other
cities once again took to the streets to
voice their anger at the military and
demand they hand over power to a
civilian government
we came out to send a message to the
military who are in power around the
country that we want a pure civilian
government the army should return to the
barracks no militia can rule a country
and i think that is a very clear message
protesters are also commemorating the
third anniversary of a sitting in front
of the army headquarters that sit-in led
the military to depose long-time
president ahmad al-bashir after months
of protests and signed a power-sharing
agreement with the protest movement an
agreement that was dissolved when the
army took over last october
we made a huge achievement in 2019 and
ended a regime stronger than the current
one they say the revolution was stolen
but it wasn't the army was in
partnership with us and they betrayed us
and this is a fresh revolution with no
partnership with the military so now we
want a civilian government without the
military we can't live under a military
rule
security forces used tear gas and live
ammunition to disperse protesters in the
past six months more than 90 protesters
have been killed and hundreds injured as
security forces use what rights groups
and the un describe as excessive and
brutal force against unarmed
demonstrators
last year's military takeover has
created a political crisis there hasn't
been a prime minister for three months
and the caretaker government is still
running the day-to-day affairs of the
country the uncertainty along with donor
countries halting financial aid sudan
following the takeover has created an
economic crisis but the army says even
with protests against its rule it won't
hand over power except to an elected
government
a joint effort by the united nations
african union and the regional
intergovernmental authority on
development or egad to facilitate talks
between the various political actors in
sudan was launched in january but many
protesters have rejected the process
this revolution will succeed whether
that happens today or tomorrow or next
year or the coming generation in 2019 we
demand the end of the regime we're
demanding that same thing now
we don't want partnerships or
negotiations or compromise with the
military
protesters have faced the threat of
violence and detention from security
forces but they say until their demands
for a civilian government and a return
to a democratic transition are met they
won't stop protesting heber morgan
al-jazeera khartoum